Welcome back.
Now that we hopefully have a
little bit of an intuition of
what a limit is, or finding
the limit of a function is,
let's do some problems.
Some of these you might
actually see on your exams or
when you're actually trying to
solve a general limit problem.
So let's say what is the
limit-- once again, my
pen is not working.
What is the limit as
x approaches-- let's
say negative 1.
And let me see, what's a good--
let's say my expression is--
I'll put it in parentheses
so it's cleaner.
It's 2x plus 2 over x plus 1.
So the first thing I would
always try to do is just say
what happens if I just stick x
straight into this expression?
What happens?
Well, what's 2x plus 2 when
x is equal to negative 1?
2 times negative 1.
2 times negative 1 plus 2
over negative 1 plus 1.
Well, the numerator is negative
2 plus 2-- that equals 0--
over-- what's the denominator?
Negative 1 plus 1.
Over 0.
And do we know
what 0 over 0 is?
Well, no.
It's undefined, right?
So here's a case, just like
what we saw in that first
video, where the limit actually
can't equal what the expression
equals when you substitute x
for the number you're trying to
find the limit of because you
get an undefined answer.
So let's see if, using the
limit, we can come up
with a better answer for
what it's approaching.
Well, since we're just starting
with these limit problems,
let me draw a graph.
And I think this is going
to give you the intuition
for what we're doing.
It'll probably give
you the answer.
But then I'll show you how
to solve this analytical.
So if I draw a graph,
these are the axes.
Actually, I'll do the
graphical and the analytical
at the same time.
So I want to rewrite this
expression in a way that
maybe I can simplify it.
So 2x plus 2.
Isn't that the same thing
as 2 times x plus 1?
2 times x plus 1, right?
2x plus 2 is the same thing as
2 times x plus one, and then
all of that is over x plus 1.
So as long as this expression
and this expression don't equal
0, it actually turns out that
this function-- let's say
this is f of x, right?
This function.
Well, for every value other
than x is equal to negative
1, you could actually
cancel this and this out.
And so really, we see that f of
x is equal to-- I need to find
a better tool-- f of x is equal
to 2 when x does not
equal negative 1.
And we saw when x is equal to
negative 1, it's undefined.
So undefined when
equals negative 1.
So how would we graph that?
We showed that f of x is equal
to 2 when x does not equal
negative 1 and f of x
is undefined when x
equals negative 1.
And once again, all I did is
kind of rewrite this exact
same function, right?
I showed that I could simplify
and I could divide the
numerator and denominator by x
plus 1 as long as x does not
equal negative 1, and that
otherwise, it's undefined.
So let me graph this.
I'm going to get a
different color.
Maybe I'll go with red.
So this is 2.
So we see that x is-- and let
me say this is negative 1.
So for every other value other
than negative 1, the value of
this, of f of x, is equal to 2.
This is 1, this is 2,
this is 3, and so on.
At negative 1, the
graph is undefined.
So there's a hole there.
And then we keep going
to the left-hand side.
So if we're going to do the
limit, we can just visually
say, well, as x-- let me
do another color now.
As x comes from the left-hand
side, what does f of x equal?
Well, f of x is 2, 2, 2, 2,
2. f of x is equal to 2
until we get to exactly
negative 1, right?
And similarly, when we go
from the other hand, it's
the exact same thing.
f of x is 2, 2, 2 until
we get to negative 1.
So you'll see, and I'll make
sure you see it visually here,
that the limit as approaches
negative 1 of 2x plus 2 over
x plus 1, it equals 2.
Let me draw a line here
so you don't get messed
up with all of it.
And I'm not formally, I guess,
proving here that the limit is
2, but I'm showing you kind of
an analytical way, and this is
actually how it tends to be
done in algebra class, is that
you tend to simplify the
expression so that you say, oh,
if there wasn't a hole here,
what would the f of
x equal, right?
And then you'd just
evaluate it at that point.
I think this might give you a
little intuition, but this
isn't a formal solution.
But unless you're asked to,
you tend not to be asked
for a formal solution.
You actually just tend to ask
what the limit is, and this is
the way you could solve it.
And actually another way that
you could-- I mean, I often
used to check my answers when I
used to do it is you could take
a calculator and try in-- what
happens when: what is f
of minus 1.001, right?
And you can also try what is
f of negative 0.999, right?
Because what you want to do is
you want to say, well, what
does the function equal when I
get really close to negative 1?
And then you could keep going
closer and closer to negative
1 and see what the function
approaches, and in this
case, you'll see that
it approaches 2.
So let's do another problem.
Well, let's say, what is
the limit as x approaches
0 of 1 over x?
I think here it might be useful
to draw this graph because
it'll give you a visual reason,
a visual represent-- actually,
let's do it both ways.
Let's say-- let's do it the
picking-numbers method because
I think that'll give you an
intuition and maybe it'll
help us draw the graph.
So let's say that
this is f of x.
f of x-- you can tell my
presentation is very
unplanned-- f of x is
equal to 1 over x.
And we want to find the
limit as x approaches 0.
So what is f of-- actually,
let's make a table.
f of x.
So clearly when x is equal
to 0, we don't know.
It's undefined.
1 over 0 is undefined.
But what happens when
x equals minus 0.01?
Well, with minus 0.01, 1 over
minus 0.01, that is equal
to negative 100, right?
What happens when x is equal
to minus 0.001, right?
So we're getting closer
and closer to 0 from
the negative direction.
Well, here it equals--
make sure my pen is
working, color right.
Something's wrong with my tool.
Now my computer's
breaking down.
Let's see what's going on.
I think my computer just froze.
Well, I'm going to try to solve
this, and in the very next
video, I'm going to continue
on with this problem.
So I'll actually see you in the
next presentation while I
figure out why my pen isn't
working, and then we'll
continue with this problem.
See you very soon.